hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ein paar tagen video hochgeladen
wo ich mal wieder geblockt habe nach ein
paar monaten bäume und darunter kamen
mega viele kommentare und ultra viel
feedback deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich reagiert einmal so ein bisschen
drauf hey luca richtig guter block würde
gerne sein wie du muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen lieber rabatt gewährt den
kommentar geschrieben crafter luca kann
ich auf jeden fall verstehen ich würde
auch gern sein wie ich meine jeder ist
so geil wie ich steck best locker ohne
spaß wenn ich irgendwann mal anfangen
sollte öfter blogs hochzuladen als alle
drei monate mal dann wäre das der heftig
ich auf jeden fall immer benutzen würde
ja klar und letzte woche als ich habe
genau den gleichen ort in amsterdam war
ist er nicht da es tut mir leid also ich
hab das ja häufig riesig vorher
angekündigt dass nach amsterdam fahren
oder so das war eigentlich fast schon
relativ spontane aktion also da waren
eine party interessierte dann haben wir
halt zwei drei wochen vorher gesagt
bekommen dass dahin zahlen weil ich fand
es halt auch wieder richtig coolen die
anderen leute auf sie eingegangen sind
dass dies ein bisschen traurig darüber
war dass sie mich nicht getroffen hat
kate wenn es richtig cool wie
herzergreifende immer umgeht
untereinander mit euch in konnte war er
schaut das video auf dem klo was seid
ihr für menschenalter wien interessiert
sowie das video ein klo schauen oder mit
socken an oder nicht ein hauptsache
guckt euch an
dann krieg ich views wer's dafür dass er
mal ein video macht wo er nur mixed
ungelogen das ist derzeit das wo ich am
meisten meiner freizeit irgendwie rein
stecke und zwar irgendwie mit dem dj
controller so ein bisschen rum spielen
und irgendwelche songs zusammen mixen
und sorgt wenn jeder haut drauf habe
dass ich irgendwann mal auf seinem kanal
ein video hochladen wo ich ihnen wie 30
minuten langen nur verschiedene tracks
inneren mixe dann schreibt man einfach
mal in die kommentare ich weiß ich habe
das auch nie so wirklich in videos so
großartig erzählt oder so aber ich denke
die leute die mir weiß selbst folgen
wissen es ja dass wir irgendwie fast
jedes wochenende irgendwo in
irgendwelchen house clubs sind und uns
mutter an hörig post weshalb jedoch so
oft sachen meine story wo irgendwelche
remixes im hintergrund laufen oder ich
selber gerade irgendwas zusammen mit
also ich glaube wenn ihr mir da folgt
wisst ihr auf jeden fall dass musik ein
großer bestandteil meines lebens ist
deswegen hatte ich echt schon in letzter
zeit überlegt okay wenn ich jetzt dass
er so viel zeit da reinstecken warum
lade ich das nicht einfach mal hoch also
wenn ihr das wollt dann schreibt mir das
einfach mal die kommentare
du hast bier gekauft das war heineken
das willst du doch nicht als bier
bezeichnet was ist das sonst heiliges
ihr eine kit ist eine niederländische
brauerei die am 12 juni 1864 von gérard
adrian heinig hin gegründet wurde die
ist der drittgrösste brauereikonzern der
welt nach anheuser busch inbev und
sabmiller da hast du heiligen ist eine
bierbrauerei mehr davon bitte das ist
auch eine sache die mir enorm oft als
kommentar unter gepackt wurde und zwar
dass leute das wirklich gefeiert haben
die ich den blog aufgebaut habe es war
für mich wirklich vorher so dass ich mir
gedacht habe ok soll ich das jetzt
wirklich locken ich habe eigentlich
keinen bock jetzt eine riesen dsl ärmel
zu nehmen und irgendwie eine drohne mehr
auszuleihen
letztendlich habe ich dann einfach so
eine ganz kleine digicam oder so
mitgenommen habe einfach gedacht kommen
wenn ich gerade bock habt dann hole ich
die kamera raus und filmen das und so
aber zwingen ich jetzt nichts dazu
irgendwas interessantes zu machen weil
ich finde einfach dass sehr viele day
die blogger ihren tag nach dem blog
aufbauen also die sagen okay ich blogge
gerade das heißt es muss doch irgendwas
interessantes passieren und da bin ich
überhaupt nicht der fan von wenn ich
irgendwann der die blogs machen sollte
und ich habe auf jeden fall bock drauf
aber dann werde ich nicht sagen okay es
ist noch nichts spannendes in dem blog
heute passiert ich werde jetzt noch
schnell ein baum fällt
also würde mich hätte dann wirklich
einfach nur diese kleine kamera dabei
und wird einfach das filmen was ich
mache und da bin ich also der ansicht
nach und deswegen so habe ich halt den
locker aufgebaut und dann hätte ich nie
gedacht dass es leute in irgendeiner
form feiern weil letztendlich habe ich
quasi nur gefilmt als mir langweilig war
mit nicht gerade das so gut ankommt bei
euch aber wenn ihr wollt dass nicht mal
öfter blog oder die blogger oder
irgendwas wenn ich irgendwie hinkriege
oder so in meinem zeitrhythmus anlass
mann lag da wie lange hast du an den
block geschnitten ich glaube so vier
stunden und mit drei weil das krasseste
waren halt dass ich vollauf dieser und
hatte ein gefühlt habe und colour
collection und cara grading das alles
hat am meisten zeit gekostet also eher
vorbereitung der stunde und schnitt dann
nochmal so dreieinhalb bis vier stunden
dieser blog ist schön aber ist er auch
gut hat die schnauze revie trinken als
vorbild von sechs bis 13 jährigen echt
cool und dann beschweren wenn andere
youtuber so etwas machen erstmal bin ich
nicht sechs oder 13 sondern 20 jahre alt
und ich darf alkohol trinken und wenn du
jetzt hier schon die moralapostel
spielst ich habe selber schon von oft
gesagt ich bin kein vorbild ihr sollt
mich nicht als vorbild nehmen und ich
weiß jetzt gar nicht wie soll ich mich
jetzt rechtfertigen muss also ich hab ja
nichts illegales getan oder so und ich
denke es ist jedem selbst überlassen ob
er mal ein bier trinken möchte oder ob
er mal irgendwie mit dem auto fahren
möchte oder was weiß ich letztendlich
völlig auch sagen dass ich dich dass du
dir das video angeguckt hat und in der
zeit nicht nach draußen gehören bis zum
sport gemacht hast oder so aber jeder
soll sein ding machen das was sie von
dem video meine davon er hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wer das getan hat las man
leicht da sitzt wahrscheinlich schon im
titel
ich werde da die blogger ich habe der
ehrlichen sagt bock drauf also schreibt
mir mal die kommentare ob das überhaupt
interessant wäre beiden daily blog wird
von mir dann vielleicht nur 34 minuten
gehen weil ich einfach nur so ein
bisschen in meinem leben gemacht film
würde wie gesagt schreib mir das einfach
ohne die kommentare wieder bock drauf
hätte die findet hier ins neue jahr
eingeläutet wenn er darauf legt ihm
einen kanal abonnieren und hier findet
ihr noch mal den block aus amsterdam
eingeblendet auf den ich mich gerade die
ganze zeit bezogen habe könnt ihr auch
aus checken
das wars vom mio